well it's good news for people that like
bad news because as bad as your holiday
season might have been it wasn't nearly
as bad as Rudy giuliani's Federal Jury
has ordered Rudy Giuliani to pay over
$148 million to Georgia election workers
Ruby Freeman and sheay Moss for falsely
claiming they committed ballot fraud in
the 20120 presidential election to some
people giuliani's fall from grace has
been a surprise but it wasn't a shock to
Rudy himself though in 2019 Giuliani was
asked if quot saying things for Trump
not always being truthful about it do
you ever worry that this will be your
legacy and his answer was yes well Rudy
don't get ahead of yourself because you
could explain it to the bankruptcy court
first because defamation claims are not
always dischargeable in bankruptcy and
he's about to spend the rest of his life
paying moss and Freeman So today we're
going to talk about the defamation case
against Giuliani his chances of getting
the award reduced on appeal and figure
out how many cameos he has to sell to
make $148 million hi Devon I'm calling
to congratulate you on a quite an
accomplishment and how much he's
actually going to have to pay now as
almost everyone knows by now Joe Biden
legitimately be Donald Trump and Georgia
ensuring that he received enough
electoral votes to replace Trump as
president but M World refused to believe
that Biden beat Trump fair and square
and Trump and his allies quickly seized
on two individual election staffers Ruby
Freeman and shean Moss as the central
villains in this plot against America
moss and Freeman are mother and daughter
Board of election workers from fton
County Georgia who helped count the
votes on Election Day and as they
alleged on December 3rd 2020 the Trump
campaign published an edited video from
a grainy security camera that showed
unidentified persons including
individuals later identified as Miss
Freeman and miss Moss counting ballots
now this video became the basis of a
conspiracy theory that Freeman and Moss
were counting suitcases full of fake
ballots and uploading more fake ballots
from thumb drives Trump named the women
in his Infamous call with Brad
raffensberger and Trump's allies also
spread these false claims but Rudy
juliani was the most visible Giuliani
appeared on o day after day claiming
that moss and Freeman were criminals how
about the videotape that I have where
they're shoving the thing into the
machine three and four times so it can
be recounted by the same two women that
earlier in the day what passing around
hard drive hard drives or flash
drives that supposedly can't be used in
Dominion machines but can right and the
complaint said that o quote leveraged
juliani's unsupported factual assertions
and almost immediately published them to
millions of its viewers and readers
subsequently adding Miss Freeman's and
Miss Moss's names and leveling
additional accusations of criminal fraud
against them and it didn't take long for
Georgia election officials to debunk
juliani's assertions about Freeman in
Moss quote Within 24 hours of juliani
and the Trump campaign's original
publication of these lies George
election officials explained that the
video contained quote no suitcases no
illegal ballot counting no election
fraud a fullhand recount of George's
election results had already confirmed
the election results and by December 7th
so would the recount requested by the
Trump campaign through December and
January Georgia's Republican election
officials continued to explain to the
public again and again that thorough
reviews had disproven defendants false
claims and proven that no illegal ballot
counting had occurred Giuliani and the
Trump campaign were not deterred though
juliani subsequently testified at a
hearing before the Georgia House of
Representatives government Affairs
committee where he played the video and
falsely claim that it showed quote voter
fraud right in front of people's eyes
and was the tip of the iceberg juliani
also discussed Freeman and moss on his
podcast in Twitter account juliani's
media appearances and the tweets
resulted in 33 million online
impressions of Freeman alone Trump's
fans who were convinced Freeman and Moss
were the ones standing in the way of his
reelection started showing up at their
homes on January 6 2021 a crowd on foot
and in vehicles surrounded Freeman's
house her online boutique was flooded
with threatening messages including
several that mentioned lynching shortly
after Giuliani tweeted the video of her
she said quote I took it as though they
were going to hang me with their ropes
on my street I was scared I didn't know
if they were coming to kill me the
complaint sted that Freeman was forced
to shutter her online business when
social media became impossible to
navigate eventually Freeman at the
recommendation of the FBI fled her home
and did not return for 2 months Moss
testified before the January 6 committee
about how something as innocuous as
passing her mother a ginger mint had now
been portrayed as her stealing a
presidential election in one of the
videos we just watched Mr Giuliani
accused you and your mother of passing
some sort of USB drive to each other uh
what was your mom actually handing you
on that video a ginger in other
testimony Freeman described how unsafe
Giuliani and Trump's actions made her
feel in her own Community I I stayed
away from my home for approximately 2
months it was horrible I felt homeless I
felt you know
I can't believe I can't believe this
person has caused this much damage to me
and my family um to have to leave my
home that I've lived there for 21 years
mtin Freeman said they received numerous
death threats quote on at least two
occasions strangers showed up at her
grandmother's home and attempted to push
into the house in order to make a
citizen's arrest on these occasions Miss
Moss's grandmother who was in her
mid-70s called her in panic confused and
scared for her safety The Fulton County
Board of Elections quote General email
address would forward incoming emails to
miss moss and many of her colleagues
filling her workplace with harassing
messages so moss and Freeman sued
Giuliani o and the other defendants for
defamation and intentional infliction of
emotional distress in most civil
defamation trials jurors first decide
whether the statements made were
defamatory and if they were defamatory
then the jury then decides whether the
person who made them intentionally
inflicted emotional distress and whether
they suffer damages however Giuliani
chose the same defense strategy as Alex
Jones when he was sued by the families
of the children killed at the Sandy Hook
Elementary School refusing to
participate in the discovery process in
good faith judge barl Howell entered a
default judgment against Giuliani before
the trial began so the jury was told
that Giuliani defamed Freeman and Moss
and that the two women were also
entitled to punitive damages the trial
was simply to determine how much
Giuliani would have to pay but that
raises the question why wouldn't
Giuliani participate in the discovery
process in good faith well there are
probably many reasons uh but some of the
most important ones are Jack Smith and
Donald Trump Giuliani is already facing
criminal charges for his participation
in the scheme to submit fake electoral
votes in Georgia he's also described as
an uncharged co-conspirator number one
in Trump's indictment on federal charges
in Washington for obstruction of the
2020 election so if Giuliani
meaningfully participated in Discovery
it's likely that Smith would get to see
everything that Giuliani produced in the
Civil Discovery process which could lead
to Giuliani being indicted in DC and on
top of it this kind of Discovery can get
extremely expensive as well Giuliani
famously is going through money problems
as well so much so that he asked for
Trump's help his ex-lawyer is suing him
for $1.3 million in unpaid legal fees
and during an August Hearing in another
case his lawyer said Rudy was close to
broke and unable to pay a number of
bills apparently making Cameo videos for
legal eagle doesn't generate enough
income to pay these huge legal bills
you're an Ace Attorney and a legal eagle
and I admire really good attorneys now a
trump Affiliated pack gave Giuliani
$350,000 and Trump held a $11,000 ahead
fundraiser for Giuliani last fall but
it's not clear how much of an impact
that has made given all these legal fees
now this whole case has been marked by a
couple of juliani's really dumb legal
strategies at one point in an effort to
stop the judge from ruling on the
Discovery issues Giuliani filed a
stipulation purporting to admit
liability stipulation is a binding
agreement between opposing parties on a
relevant issue in the case uh juli on
stipulation said he quote does not
contest that his statements were false
and carry meaning that is Def atory per
se he was also willing to offer that his
statements met the factual elements of
liability for moss and Freeman's claims
that his attacks amounted to intentional
Affliction of emotional distress and
civil conspiracy the idea being that
Rudy would offer these stipulations in
exchange for not actually having to
produce discovery that would have led to
those factual conclusions but Rudy and
sibl seemed to bungle the stipulation
because it included a disclaimer saying
that he reserved the right to claim that
his statements weren't defamatory after
all on appeal Sibly said that the
stipulation wasn't an admission of
liability it was a decision not to test
the lawsuit but as judge how concluded
quote juliani stipulations hold more
holes than swiss cheese with his latest
stipulation expressly reserving his
arguments that these statements
complained of are protected and
non-actionable opinion for purposes of
appeal she wrote that just as taking
shortcuts to win in election carries
risks even potential criminal liability
bypassing the discovery process carries
serious sanctions no matter what
reservations a non-compliant party may
try artificially to preserve for appeal
now obviously Rudy really would have
benefited from a good lawyer during this
whole process but if you want a great
lawyer my firm the eagle team can help
if you've suffered a data breach
especially if you've got a data breach
letter were involved in a car crash or
dealt with sexual harassment we can
represent you or help find you the right
attorney it's important to talk to a
lawyer right away so you can get the
best representation to find out what
your options are so just click on the
link in the description for a free
consultation with my team because you
don't just need a legal team you need
the eagle team the link is down below
but it's also worth taking a quick look
at judge how's scathing opinion about
giuliani's conduct in this case when a
party is on notice that that there will
be litigation they are required to
preserve potentially relevant evidence
including electronically stored
information which is known as ESI if a
party fails to take steps to preserve
ESI quote and it cannot be restored or
replaced through additional Discovery a
court May order measures no greater than
necessary to cure the Prejudice this
misconduct also known as spoliation is
the destruction or material alteration
of evidence or the failure to preserve
properly for another's use as evidence
in pending or reasonably foreseeable
litigation judges and lawyers take this
kind of thing very seriously because if
evidence is destroyed then you have a
much harder time making your case and
believe me we lawyers really enjoy going
through your ESI including your emails
because that's where all the juicy
information is so destruction of
evidence is serious so upon a finding
that the party acted with the intent to
deprive another party of the
information's use in the litigation a
court is empowered to impose severe
sanctions including presuming that the
Lost information was unfavorable to the
party instructing the jury that it May
or must presume the information was
unfavorable to the party or dismissing
the action or entering a default
judgment the judge here found that
Giuliani should have preserved ESI as
early as January of 2021 but did not
take reasonable steps to preserve it and
didn't even turn off the auto delete
until later that same year judge how
pointed out that Giuliani isn't some
regular guy who's never seen the inside
of a courtroom and doesn't know anything
about preserving evidence quote the fact
that Giuliani is a sophisticated
litigant with a self-professed 50 years
of experience in litigation includ
serving as the US attorney for the
southern district of New York only
underscores his lackluster preservation
efforts Giuliani argued that the FBI was
responsible for destroying the ESI the
FBI confiscated giuliani's devices uh
because he's facing criminal charges
quote when the devices were finally
returned to Giuliani the Costello
declaration repeats giuliani's assertion
that all the devices had been wiped
clean by the vendor for the government
uh but without any verification of this
fact by any expert forensic examiner or
even a professional Information
Technology professional and judge Hal
had reason to believe Giuliani acted
intentionally plaintiffs obtained
responsive documents produced by Third
parties including giuliani's assistance
which should have been turned over by
Giuliani himself in a footnote the judge
said quote indeed the house select
committee released a December 13th 2020
email from Giuliani to epin in which
Giuliani approved a draft statement from
the Trump legal team that stated quote
Georgia has video evidence of 30,000
illegal ballots cast after The Observers
were removed referencing giuliani's
false claim about the plaintiffs yet
juliani never produced that email to
plaintiffs nor as far as plaintiff's
council can discern did he ever claim
privilege over it and according to judge
how the ESI has now been irretrievably
lost so why did that justify a default
judgment well because giuliani's ESI was
relevant to all of the plaintiff's
claims Giuliani argued that Ruby Freeman
is a limited purpose public figure which
means she would have had to show that
Giuliani statements about her were made
with actual malice that means Freeman
would have to prove that Giuliani
published false statements concerning
her with knowledge that it was false or
with Reckless disregard about whether it
was false or not quote without access to
circumstantial evidence of julani State
of Mind in the form of uh his messages
and email Communications with Associates
or other contemporaneous records of his
thoughts when he made the false
statements against Freeman plaintiffs
are severely hampered in being able to
refute giuliani's defense that he made
his statements about Freeman merely
negligently the same was true of their
other claims intentional infliction of
emotional distress and civil conspiracy
Jal entered judgment against Jani as a
discovery sanction and set a trial to
determine damages however even after his
Discovery abuse judge how gave Rudy one
last chance to avoid total disaster
quote as this case now heads to trial to
determine any damages due to plaintiff's
claims Giuliani will be given a final
opportunity to comply with Discovery
relevant to the determination of Damages
both compensatory imput or face
imposition of additional Discovery
related sanctions under rule 37 B2 in
the form of adverse instructions and
exclusion of evidence at trial now
Giuliani could have mitigated the amount
amount to the damages owed to him if he
produced evidence about his personal net
worth and paid plaintiff's legal fees
but Giuliani chose not to and by the
time the case went to trial on Damages
he had less ability to challenge the
plaintiff's estimation of their damages
so what is giuliani's net worth and how
much money can Rudy actually pay the two
women he defamed well we don't know uh
he didn't comply with judge how's order
to turn over information on his finances
during the trial juliani's lawyer argued
that he didn't have any money but
without admissible evidence to back that
up is argu fell flat the pl's attorney
Michael gaunle told jurors that Giuliani
is still a celebrity who makes frequent
media appearances and has a deal with
right-wing Network Newsmax quote
Giuliani profited from these lies we
don't know how much so got Le asked the
jury to punish Giuliani with punitive
damages the plaintiff's expert witness
Ashley humph of Northwestern University
estimated that they were entitled to18
to $48 million to compensate for the
loss of their reputations that was the
amount that she believed it would take
to restore their images through a social
media campaign uh Humphrey cited the
huge interest in online misinformation
about them after Giuliani and Trump
publicly accused them of sabotage got Le
said that if Moss had been able to stay
in her job as an election worker which
paid $39,000 a year would have made
about $800,000 over her lifetime now
interestingly Giuliani initially said he
would testify a trial but his lawyer
Joseph sibl changed his mind at the last
minute saying unbelievably but
accurately quote these two women have
been through enough and Sibly argued for
compassion admitting that Giuliani
didn't Injustice to the plaintiffs but
that he was just a 79-year-old man who
believes in conspiracy theories sibl
repeatedly compared his client to a flat
earther uh and finally he argued during
his closing that the jury should
remember the time that juliani saved the
city after 911 Sibly said his client was
a unifying figure not the broken old
conspiracy theorist he is today quote
this is a man who did great things if he
hasn't been so great lately I want you
to judge him by his entire character of
who he is the jury seemingly did so in
return to verdict of 148 million Freeman
was awarded $16.1 million for the Damage
Done to her reputation Moss was awarded
$16.9 million for the damage to her
reputation each woman was awarded $20
million for the emotional distress
caused by juliani's defamation and
finally Giuliani was fined $75 million
in punitive damages for defaming them so
will he have to pay all that $148
million well probably not and certainly
not anytime soon uh he's probably going
to appeal the verdict but even an appeal
won't provide him with total
there are some limitations on how big
punitive damages Wards can be and they
can't be too big of a multiple of the
actual damages probably not more than a
singled digigit multiplier uh they also
can't be too large a percentage of the
defendant's net worth uh in some cases
courts have said the punitives can't be
more than 10% of their net worth but
even here this argument runs into a
major obstacle giuliani's Discovery
abuse now if a party refuses Discovery
into their own net worth and abuses the
discovery process they aren't allowed to
appeal on the basis of the ward being
excessive in light of their net worth
and even if juliani got a good result
from the court of appeals such as
completely wiping out all the punitive
damages he would still owe tens of
millions of dollars now generally a
party who owes damages has 30 days
before the judgment is enforced however
Freeman and Moss filed a motion asking
for the 30-day automatic stay to be
dissolved because of the risk that
Giuliani would use that time to conceal
his assets judge Howell agreed and
issued an order finding that Giuliani
must immediately pay the $148 million
judge how concluded the quote Giuliani
has proven himself to be an unwilling
and uncooperative litigant who blew off
the Court's Discovery deadlines didn't
disclose his financial information and
ignored the Court's orders to pay
attorney fees judge how said quote as
plaintiffs submit and as Giuliani does
not contest Giuliani has numerous and
mounting debts including his own
attorneys and other litigant seeking to
reduce their claims to judgment now
despite these debts judge Hal questioned
whether Giuliani is really skinn quote
uh nowhere in opposition does julan
promise not to hide assets from
plaintiffs nor does he contend let alone
demonstrate with do documentary or other
proof that he would be unable to satisfy
the Judgment in whole or in part she
says he owns property in Florida in New
York and appears to have Accounts at
several financial institutions the order
concludes that Giuliani is unlikely to
succeed on appeal and in yet more bad
news for Rudy the judge said she'll
probably require him to post an appeal
Bond equivalent to the Judgment if he
wants to appeal if he has to post a bond
it would be harder for him to draw down
his assets but of course later that same
day surprise surprise Giuliani filed for
chapter 11 bankruptcy according to the
filing giuliani's net worth is between 1
and 10 million but he owes around give
or take
151,925
1859.jpg
money to Noel dumphrey who sued him for
sexual harassment Dominion who sued him
for defamation and hun Biden who sued
Rudy for hacking his laptop and he also
owes an unstated amount to his own
company Julian partners and $30,000 for
an unpaid phone bill so naturally this
all leads to a question of bankruptcy
now a person can discharge some types of
debts in bankruptcy but intentional
torts are often treated differently
intentional torts involve actions where
the wrongdoer intended to cause harm
such as battery or sometimes defamation
section 523a of the United States
Bankruptcy code outlines the kinds of
debts that are generally not
dischargeable quote a bankruptcy
discharge releases the debtor from
personal liability for certain specified
types of debts in other words the debtor
is no longer legally required to pay any
debts that are discharged debts arising
from willful and malicious injury to
another person for their property are
among the debts that may be
non-dischargeable for debt to be
excluded from bankruptcy discharge the
debtor must prove that his actions
weren't willful and malicious but
Giuliani would have a really hard time
proving that especially since he's now
continued his defamatory taxs on Freeman
and Moss yeah Giuliani is now following
the Trump blueprint of losing a
defamation Case by repeating the false
claims and then being sued Again by the
same plaintiffs juliani made several
comments after the trial including
appearances on Newsmax and Steve
bannon's podcast where he trashed the DC
trial court and repeated allegations
about plaintiffs and inexplicably he
even went after moss and Freeman on the
courthouse steps after the verdict that
what I said was true and that whatever
happened to them which is it's
unfortunate if other people overreacted
but everything I said about them is true
so I guess I already need to make
another video about his future
defamation claims in fact there are so
many claims that I can't release
everything on YouTube but thanks to the
power of today's sponsor nebula you can
watch all my videos add free and early
now I'm not only on nebula but I'm also
a co-owner because nebula is a streaming
platform built for creators by creators
and for the holidays they are doing
something completely wild nebula is
offering until the end of the month a
lifetime membership instead of a
subscription it's a one-time payment
that will get you everything nebula
offers forever and for the first time
ever nebula is also allowing people to
buy gift cards so you can gift a
lifetime subscription of nebula to a
friend or loved one and I know tens of
thousands of you signed up for nebula
using the Curiosity stream bundle but
unfortunately that is ending curiosity
stream has informed us and even included
in their latest SEC filing that they
don't intend to pay us bundle Revenue
through 2024 this means that my Creator
friends and I won't get any money for
bundle subscribers so the bundle is
breaking and you're not going to be able
to have access to nebula anymore after
2024 if you signed up with curiosity
stream maybe I'll make a video about
that soon but if you'd like to support
me and other educational creators the
only way to ensure that the money that
you spend on nebula goes to us directly
is to sign up directly so no nebula is
not going bankrupt on the contrary it's
more successful than it's ever been but
we're offering lifetime memberships for
a select few fans so that we can make
even more original content huge
Productions from your favorite creators
like new seasons of jetlag or Patrick
Williams holiday special and we're in it
for the long haul lifetime memberships
allow us to not take on outside
investors it's the opposite of a going
out of business sale it's a going into
bigger business sale and if you're new
here nebula includes tons of exclusive
videos From Me original series from your
favorite people movies plays classes and
more with your favorites like Johnny
Harris Neo jet lag real engineering real
life lore and legal eagle we create the
content that other people react to but
like I said until the end of the month
you can get an exclusive lifetime
membership it's $300 for life no tricks
no gimmicks that's it forever and if
that's not your speed that's completely
fine you can still get a 40% discount on
yearly that pencils out to less than $3
per month and if you want to pay monthly
you have that option too and now if you
want to share love you can gift a
lifetime subscription to anyone else so
click on the link that's on screen right
now or down below to get your lifetime
membership or a huge 40% discount just
click right now before the deal goes
away and after that click on this link
over here for more legal eagle or I'll
see you in court